one of the things that are so
interesting about her poems is that they
not only include expressions of shaiba
or Hindu philosophy but also traces of
Islam and Sufism through Arabic and
Persian phrases
this shouldn't be too surprising given
the fact that Lala lived in a diverse
environment where different religious
Traditions existed simultaneously and
were influenced by each other
in particular there are quite a few
similarities between Islamic teachings
as understood through Sufism and those
of Kashmir shaivism Lal dead interacted
with the sufis of her day were probably
inspired by them and indeed inspired
them in turn but for these reasons Lal
dead is claimed by different communities
the sufis of the Rishi order see her as
one of their own foundational figures
due to her relationship with people like
nondrishi whereas shaivas and Hindus
claim her for themselves it can often
become a political discussion in that
way but as we've seen the situation is a
bit more complicated than that